[Musique]
tu as fait tout ça pour la thune alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya très peu de business
non ça vous intéresse plus de faire de
la tune peut-être pour moi la série et
reflète héros fait l'univers du rap ont
tout pour moi c'est ce que je me suis
dit quand j'ai vu les épisodes aussi en
tant que spectateur et tu la prends
tellement de peine parce que tu dis ok
je sais plus délié le vrai du faux seins
playa master qui arrive va dans le
studio b tu vérifies si la crème angola
quoi parce qu'il faut pas qu'ils se
croisent toutes les histoires de deux
traits de crédibilité ou toutes ces
histoires d'égo est ce que vous pensez
vous pouvez vous réconcilier on avait là
il est rappelé pour seraient concernées
alors qu'est ce qui fait que deux mecs
qui vendent des millions de vies se
retrouve par exemple dans un aéroport
sur la gueule ils entendront faire une
opa charisme fait on comprend pourquoi
ça peut arriver et à quel point c'est
réaliste
je savais déjà un petit peu tout ce qui
se passait derrière dans les studios
dans les labels
dans les maisons de disques dans tout ça
les enregistrements l'écriture les
droits à compagnie la rivalité entre
entre entre les artistes puis gauche
c'est bon c'est vrai qu'il a il a ce
côté un peu rêveur d'arriver dans un
milieu qui connaît pas et où il l'a
fantasmer depuis des années des années
sauf qu'en fait c'est pas exactement ça
enfin si je comprends bien tout efois en
vérité il ya aucun buzz autant demain ce
sera le parcours d'apache il est c'est
le parcours d'un mec qui est propulsé
dans un milieu médiatique est là dans le
milieu du rap mais enfin c'est un truc
que tu te jettes son filet quoi tu vois
chaque semaine ya booska-p ou demolition
qui sortent de nouvelles têtes à la
roquette hongrie l'effort c'est pas le
seul tout au long de cette série il est
confronté à des des embûches qui sont
très réalistes soit qu'ils sont des
choses qui sont arrivées sur des choses
qui vraiment pourrait arriver il dit les
villes et mauvais contrats les contrats
des contrats un peu foireux il vit le
producteur qui veut juste se faire
bronzer sur son dos si nous annonce une
tournée solo je les envoie dans l'oubli
et moi je laisserais xvi le rappeur qui
nous fait croire que c'est ce qu'il ya
alors qu en fait pas du tout mais pas
tous ont partagé le gâteau je vous dis
direct c'est à dire quoi ça il n'y a pas
assez de place pour moi star carnage n'a
pas géré la maison master ne voit pas
arriver il ne voit pas arriver il se
prend un coup mais il se dit qu'en fait
il va l'étendre au fur et à mesure de
leur relation il se rend compte qu'il
n'a pas à l'état
donc c'est là où on rentre un peu plus
dans le dip un peu plus dans le dur où
justement il se sent menacé
j'ai un plan dans la tête performante et
très vite ça profiter autant à toi comme
moi tu me fous tu vois
[Musique]
basterds n'est pas la prison et s'est
montré presque tout le temps j'aimerais
que tout le monde car match et une poule
1 que va chercher ma star justement pour
essayé d'entraver la carrière de clément
je vais le prendre ils étouffent ou que
je vais le lâcher sur le clément
c'est un très bon rappeur est il ce qui
est intéressant c'est justement si la
douce côté animal en fait on saura pas
parce qu'on leur a perdu qu'on maintient
dans la vie casquette intégral témoin ce
qu ténois pas autant d'habileté plutôt
trafic
cariat méritait autant le flou qui te
prêter oui moi un mec comme carnage
envie de croiser dans une rue à la
troisième du match retour des berges et
c'est moi [ __ ] de poids aux films de
la saison je pense que vraiment ce qui
va apprendre sur lui même c'est que ma
c'est que justement sont pas être trop
gentil en fait je pense que ce sont à la
fois en fait c'est un mec durable qui
est dans le calcul dans l'analyse et
dans la stratégie
moralement c'est un coup marketing et
l'entrant retourner contre tout le monde
nous n'avons pas plus de précisions à
l'heure actuelle mais il pourrait s'agir
d'un règlement de comptes
khalid est une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal